nous l'appellerons justin 39 ans chef
cuisinier il ya encore deux ans un jour
elle sert des repas en milieu
pénitentiaire et se laisse tenter par
une reconversion
[Applaudissements]
bonjour bonjour croirait votre métier
l'a déjà fait connaître pour avoir envie
de faire faut le connaître et c'est pas
donné à tout le monde donc pour moi j'ai
eu la chance d'avoir déjà une approche
du métier avant de pouvoir me lancement
en concours ce matin elle termine son
second stage pratique prise de service
6h45 découverte du menu du jour et des
angoisses de la nuit mais au moment où
le fait de faire beaucoup de tapage au
bruit ou alors juste avoir envie de
parler ou peut-être dire à ce moment là
lancer un petit message comprend une fin
à ses jours
donc c'est quelque chose qui peut
arriver tous les ans une partie des
élèves surveillants abandonne dès les
premières semaines passées en prison le
camion ça a été des questions sur
sur le rôle du surveillant sur sur son
positionnement sur le fait d'avoir peur
ou pas des personnes détenues parce que
on soutient les personnes détenues sel
sont là ainsi que c'est pas un enfant de
coeur donc sont dangereux donc est ce
que je vois un train euros pour moi mais
la visite lui réservent des surprises
mineure de 13 ans rappelle cette jeune
fille était contente parce que d'être là
elle était consciente que c'était pas
une récompense un que c'était bien une
punition
elle était contente d'être là parce
qu'on s'occupait d'elle pour autant la
jeune femme connaît les règles par
mois'' une détenue et une détenue
ici elles sont 43 ans tous prévenus en
attente de jugement ou condamnés pour
des faits mineurs deux ans de peine au
maximum on aura tous les cracks nous
faut garder pour toujours se protéger
vous avez la crainte d'être sur une
coursive avec un refrain qui arrive
derrière et pour une raison qui a
justifié comme ça peut être le cas être
étranglés par les airs donc ben on
apprend seront cédés yeux dans l'eau
voilà pour garder ses distances
il y a le protocole fouilles aléatoires
par exemple on rentre dans l'intimité
des gens aussi et surtout en même temps
ça fait partie des conditions ça peut
expliquer des situations si on voit
comme je le disais un traitement qui
traînent on peut être comprendre
pourquoi en ce moment là personne à
l'angoissé parce que s'il ya en effet
elle a arrêté son traitement
une chasse aux indices il faut débusquer
les trafics évidemment mais depuis
quelques années on cherche aussi des
témoins de la vie quotidienne la prison
s'est intéressée à ces prisonniers
j'avais une image un peu comme beaucoup
de personnes avant c'est à dire qu un
côté un peu son sale avec des odeurs un
peu répugnante ou quoi que ce soit ou ou
des surveillants
des matons que nous avons un très fermé
pas forcément souriant pour moi ça me
paraissait inimaginable que les
personnes détenues soit en train de
laver les sols d'un couloir ou
distribuer les repas ou donc je me rends
compte que chaque personne en détention
est amené à voir forum des formations
qui font salle comble des petits boulots
pour les plus méritantes une aide à la
réinsertion
justin l'avouer elle n'aurait jamais
choisi ce métier s'il n'avait pas autant
il vaut lui c'est bon pour entendre
autour c'est bon je sais pas du social
alors c'est pas qu'on fasse du social
c'est pour faire votre métier
notre métier c'est une petite part le
social et ben pourquoi pas je trouve que
c'est valorisant moi une dernière
évaluation puis dès le mois de juin la
future surveillante prendra ses
fonctions quelque part en france
en attendant l'administration
pénitentiaire recrutent vous avez
jusqu'au 4 mai sa voix je vous ai pas
trop court patienter